thieves want discount on sentence all
right cat this is amazing two Colorado
thieves tried to get their felony charge
dropped to a misdemeanor arguing that
what they stole was on
sale so would fall below the $2,000
threshold required for a felony
conviction the jury didn't buy it and
convicted them anyway but you got to
respect thieves that appreciate the
value of a dollar yeah yeah you know
what I bet you also while while they
were in that hearing they were the only
people ever to really wish they had
Cole's
[Laughter]
cash like I haven't been to I didn't
even know Kohl's was still around I used
to fight in Kohl's with my mom all the
time like I still have nightmares we
would get into the worst fights in
Kohl's over like how I wasn't allowed to
wear get short shorts and i' be like you
don't like you don't don't love me and
like it' just escalate from there and
I'd be grounded but I still get emails
like being like you have Call's cash so
if they would have had one of those
emails then they probably would have
been good you know you know what's
interesting um Tyrus could you apply
this logic to murder you would down well
hear me out downgrade homicide because
the victim is older so somehow there was
less remaining life
stolen right why did you kill everybody
in the house they was
home she was old she was asking for
it
it just goes to show how
stupid we've become as a
society I want to know who was their
attorney yeah I want that name because
if I am ever in trouble and I'm sitting
with my war team and this is what they
came up with I think you should just say
you thought it was a sale buy one steal
one
free okay I think that's going to work
with the jury mhm they're just
giv what is it lawyer ships away these
days like the bar is clearly free now
it's the bar is this low that was your
attorney yeah like wow it's
theoretically thieves should wait until
their things are on sale Before They
smash and grab they'd be like everybody
else but apparently coupons only apply
to people buying things lus do you
employ this logic when you're
shoplifting do you you know when you go
when you go to that your local drugstore
and there's that heavily discounted card
table when you know that sells markdown
lotions and old calendars come on every
drugstore has a little table with like
stuff and it's got dust just a dollar
you're wow it's it's toothpaste from
1978 yes that's a deal you just got to
make sure you don't go over that $2,000
limit right like I'm waiting for the
middle-aged white guys to get together
and just all like let's go to the golf
store let's all get new Putters you know
that's I like I like the creativity of
criminals like when they have time to
reflect like when when the when the
chips are down they get really creative
and they're like oh no it was on sale so
if you apply the sales right that's the
kind of outside the box thinking we need
more of MH like we should put criminals
in charge of more stuff yes right like
cuz seriously you hand them an old Apple
they're going to make like a box of wine
like how they even do that right they
can make a crossbow out of Li you know
old like freaking Mouse whiskers and
some pubes you know it's like how do you
why are they not running NASA you give
them you give them a juice box and a big
lighter we'll be on Mars
tomorrow how great would it be if one of
their buddies showed up to bail them out
with Cole's
cash to be
fair there's a Kohl's in mandville
Louisiana if you want to forward me that
Kohl's cash I I will give shorts you
were never allowed to get yes Merry
Christmas God I'm so old I remember uh
what are those called uh Green Stamps
what are the stamps
us SN Green
Stamps my mom would put them in I I'd
sit down and put them in the thing and
you I wouldn't even know what you'd get
I think she just did that to keep me
busy Charlie yeah there was a set on the
thing just like lick all these Greg and
just take a nap probably what it was
Green Stamps make me sleepy
Mommy I I heard Charlie that when they
were making their getaway they asked the
cashier if they validate of course they
did I just think they should have been
smarter like they should have brought
someone like me with them on their
shoplifting spre because I can find all
the good deals I definitely feel like I
could have kept them under
$2,000 helped them to avoid a felony
charge
and also I have to say I respect it a
little bit because it was a 50-year-old
guy and a 37y old guy and of all the
things and coals they decided to lift a
KitchenAid mixer would any men here
think to steal that of all the things in
the store what were they that's the
Brilliance of their plan no that's the
that's the stupidity of men they did it
for a
[Laughter]
woman when are we going to see the game
show Smash and grab right that's what
you do with these department stores I'm
going to get arrested when I try to buy
her shorts with coal cash expired and
then on the news they going to see me
with a really small child short Co this
is great publicity for Kohl's though
because cat like you said a lot of us
didn't even know it was still open but
now we do yeah well that was the Hobby
Lobby you can't miss it the Hobby
Lobby all right coming up is it a work
of fiction or could Civil War be a real
depiction hey hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else